you've been through it all and at 45
you land a role and i noticed this
because i kept checking because i'm
weird that your instagram just kept
going up and up it was like 120 140 160
200 220 240 like all these people are
following you and your your imd
pro meter number was just
going down and down and down and down is
good because the lower numbers is and
i'm like
good for [ __ ] dave das mulchin
i mean how do you feel right now we're
gonna get in this because i want to go
back in time a little bit
but um how are you feeling about all
this
thank you for asking thank you for the
compliments i love you you know i'm a
huge fan of your work and i've been a
fan of your work since long before i
actually met you
in person on the back porch at james
gunn's house i've been a fan of yours
for a very long time so that's very nice
and touches my heart thank you very much
um i
two things
the first
is i have been in a bubble for since
june i was in berlin with my family
and then to malta come you know
beginning of um august and
in both of those bubbles we are not only
in a coveted bubble for production but
also the bubble of like my reality has
been being on this boat fighting dracula
or being with my family and
completely out of touch with everything
that's going on in the rest of my life
including you know family back home and
my things happening with my career back
home and so my kind of
context and connection to all of this
has been through
social media yeah and like texts and
the the my phone and so that has been
weird but nice people have been very
nice and thank god um people have been
very supportive of some of the stuff
recently that's you know blown up but um
the other thing and i'm glad and i hope
we could talk about this today because i
know you're not going to shy away from
talking about um
you know the stuff that is a little more
you know
awkward or uncomfortable and i'm i've
been wrestling with this i've been um
i've been in kind of a
uh
uh i i've been definitely below my
baseline airing towards the depressive
because i i could go down to
deep depression and i can go way up into
you know high anxiety and and manic
modes and so finding my baseline is kind
of
part of my daily
journey if you will it's my lifelong
journey just being at peace and serene
with like that baseline
being
i'm struggling
with the fact that i feel so grateful
that like you're saying like my
followers
all of a sudden doubled and tripled and
quadrupled and people were being so
gracious and kind and
neat new professional opportunities were
kind of flowering and lots of exciting
wonderful neat things happening
um
and yet
my family had to leave and go back to
the us about a month ago and that's
really hard for me they are a big part
of my um
not only my support system but kind of
just
probably in an unhealthy way i am i am
insanely dependent upon even the kids
for a lot of my um
settling and baselining and and i need
to work on that because i am a grown
adult and i should be able to do that
without you know
leaning on others but they they are
they're a big part of that and um
and i faced some really difficult
moments in the course of making this
film that i'm working on that made me
feel
dark and those were both creative
moments and also
just production moments to be quite
frank and someday we'll have coffee and
i can download you on all of it but just
needless to say you know sometimes this
business can really
make you f really hurt and um
and so all these wonderful things are
happening and and then at night i'm
laying there feeling
really blue and dark and i've been
wrestling with this kind of a sense of
guilt over not just being like
so happy all the time that like
james's movie turned out so awesome and
people loved it and you know polka dot
man's so cool and the doing stuff looks
so cool and
uh so many neat things are happening and
so
that
i've been wrestling to be honest lately
in other words you're wrestling with the
fact that you have so much to be
grateful for but you feel so down which
is making you upset that you're feeling
so down about all the good that's
happening around you and you quite can't
quite
understand it or wrap your head around
it